President Trump is also appearing to
rejoice over the confusion in Iowa short
time ago he tweeted this the Democrat
caucus is an unmitigated disaster
nothing works just like they ran the
country tonight the president will
deliver a State of the Union address in
the same house chamber where he was
impeached just a day before the US
Senate is expected to acquit him Nancy
Nancy Cordes rather is on Capitol Hill
with more on this story Nancy the
president sure has a lot to discuss
tonight how likely is it you think that
he'll bring up impeachment well
Republicans Gale are urging him not to
dwell on impeachment to focus instead on
the economy or his plans for the
upcoming year but they acknowledge it
will be hard for him to resist the urge
to hit back at his critics Democrats and
Republicans the president's behavior was
shameful and wrong Alaska senator Lisa
Murkowski is the latest Republican to
condemn President Trump though she said
she would not vote to remove him I
cannot vote to convict the Constitution
provides for impeachment but does not
demand it in all instances she joins a
series of Republicans who say they will
vote to acquit the House didn't approve
Trump committed a crime House
impeachment managers and the president's
legal team made their final pleas
yesterday ahead of Wednesday's vote you
can't trust this president to do the
right thing not for one minute not for
one election not for the sake of our
country you just can't
the defense insisted the Democrats case
does not meet the high bar for
impeachment the only appropriate result
here is to acquit the President and to
leave it to the voters to choose their
president mr. cotton no Senate Democrats
are still angry about Friday's close
vote against new witnesses we must call
this what it was it's a cover-up but
your fear of this bully cannot outweigh
your duty to the American people one
Democrat who is on the fence West
Virginia's Joe Manchin I remain
undecided on how I will vote his state
went for
in Trump by 42 points in 2016
yesterday he proposed a middle ground
his behavior cannot go unchecked by the
Senate and censure would allow a
bipartisan statement condemning his
unacceptable behavior in the strongest
terms his proposal has not gained much
traction yet the president continued to
attack the process from the sidelines
Monday Republicans are urging him not to
dwell on impeachment when he addresses
Congress and the nation tonight there's
a lot of things that he needs to talk
about we've got the hottest economy
we've ever had I would stick on that
news everywhere you look today Nancy
thank you
you